comment se comporter lorsqu'on assiste
un spectacle car sacha guitry il a dit
avant nous de même qu'il y a de bons ou
de mauvais acteurs les spectateurs ont
plus ou moins de talent intéressé que
nous sommes à l'amélioration de l'espèce
nous avons eu l'idée de composer à
l'intention d'autres au public une sorte
de code du spectateur fruit d'une déjà
longue observation d'abord l'entrée dans
la salle
vous êtes en retard le spectacle est
commencée depuis 20 bonnes minutes
même si vous êtes une personnalité un
aux tables faites vous tout petit
écraser vos coms là un guichetier de
déranger vos voisins et fatalement les
artistes savent a serré ça va mieux à
ces gestes on a loupé le début que le
spectacle est quelquefois dans la salle
mais celui qui est sur scène risque
parfois d'en souffrir si décidément vous
arrivez encore ce qui est très mal mais
parfois excusable eu égard aux
difficultés de la circulation et du
parking à l'heure du théâtre que se
soigne en pis ou simplement distraction
faites tout de même attention vos posé
les pieds et le reste dans le camp
merveilleux d'un spectacle comique qui
tiendrait ses promesses
laissez vous aller bien sûr riez pouffer
esclaffé vous tordez vous de banque un
mais on évite autant que possible de le
faire à contretemps une inflexion du
genre voit la tronche
pouvez-vous être que ces excès
d'enthousiasmé risque parfois de gêner
l'entourage serait ce pas aussi gênante
l'attitude contraire qui consiste à
traumatiser littéralement tout
spectateur qui savourait comme il
convient l'humour de l' ouvrage
représente et humour dont la subtilité
elle semble heureuse si moh vous
échapper elle rêvait kyo même je suis
désolé je suis l'auteur
or la liste des casseurs d'ambiance le
plus redouté et d'écouté de la rampe
enfants en bas âge amateurs de bonbons
dans leur paquet chien dépressif et
cetera le photographe amateur ou
professionnel en mérite une place de
choix tant il est vrai que la
désinvolture de son comportement et son
évidente à différence aux péripéties de
la représentation qui se déroule devant
lui freeze quelquefois le sabotage
il ya aussi la dame bilingue qui offre à
son compagnon étrangers et à quelques
autres une version doublée presque
simultanées cohabitent chez nietzsche et
qu'elle a la garde sa part d'internet en
national wolfang amadeus ou cadres ntv
le cognac époux thann
il y a le joyeux drilles farceur de
service qui recherchent le dialogue
entre la salle et la scène et l'odeur
étrange et puis il y a les silencieux
qui ne réagissent pas qui ne branche pas
qui ne rient pas ne sourit pas ils sont
généralement placés au premier rond il
nous regarde fixement avec une sorte de
rancune proches de l'oeil qui est
extrêmement traumatisant pour une
sensibilité d'artiste même dans une
solde 3000 personnes chauffée à blanc
nous ne voyons plus que nous sommes
fascinés par e.on il a ce demander mais
qu'est ce qu'on leur a fait à ces deux
là je ne bouge pas ne bougeront pas
refusant de participer à l'euphorie
générale dans un nul qui m'a front to
man